while it is now just passed 1300 GMT and
we begin in Moscow where the Russian
government says it's stopped an
assassination attempt targeting
President Vladimir Putin says two drones
were used in the attack on the
presidential residence inside the
Kremlin it happened in the early hours
of Wednesday morning Russian authorities
say Ukraine was behind it the Ukrainian
government meanwhile has strongly denied
those allegations well let's bring in
Pavel falgenhauer he's a defense and
Military amnest he joins us now from
Moscow Pavo let's start with the type of
attack you certainly audacious if indeed
that's what it was what sort of a drone
could we be talking about
oh it's hard to say which kind of drones
were used but apparently we can have see
footage of something exploding over the
Kremlin across the Red Square so
apparently something was there in the
air and it kind of was taken down by the
Russian defense leaders of the crime one
though it's not of course a directly a
kind of attack on Putin most likely in
the night time he doesn't tend to be in
the Kremlin at all it doesn't live in
the crown one uh he goes there for work
in working hours and then returns to his
country residence Dutch outside of
Moscow and then returns back to the
Kremlin on a limousine Convoy so but
Putin was not there at all when this
alleged attack happened I want to ask
you about that because obviously if
Putin wasn't even in Moscow at the time
time doesn't that seem a little
incongruous that whoever had the
intelligence to carry out an attack like
this didn't seem to know the president
wasn't even in the city
well it's not the technical enough he's
in Moscow but he's not in the Kremlin
he's in the outskirts of his Dutch most
likely but of course the president's
itinerary is a very uh titanically held
secret as it should be in Wartime uh but
there's a problem and then there that
comes on next week on May 9th at May 9th
at 10 o'clock in the morning Putin has
to be in the red square at the stand to
observe the Victory Day parade and
actually the footage that appeared is
these drones being taken down apparently
taken down uh close to that stand you
see the standard has been built in Red
Square for Putin
so and that's at the time of the day and
year uh 9th of May 10 o'clock where
Butch in the dinner is well known way in
advance he should be there so and it's a
the grandma said that this wedge drone
attack was a dry run a preparation for
May the 9th when Putin will be
vulnerably because his whereabouts are
known in advance well I see the Kremlin
is saying that that May 9th parade is
still going to go ahead regardless but
as you alluded to there these drones
were seemingly taken down by something
do we have any idea of what that could
have been
well there are different kind of
anti-drone capabilities there near the
in the Kremlin there are uh Panzer s
that can use either missiles or uh heavy
machine guns so something apparently
there did explode it's hard to say
exactly what but these sponsor and the
aircraft systems have been deployed in
Central Moscow that's also been known
already for some months Pavel I believe
there's been some speculation about
radar defense systems being used by the
Kremlin and especially in this case I
mean we've also seen smoke though which
suggested that there was some kind of
damage
uh well something went down there
and something also I could hit the
ground they say that this was no one got
injured uh yes the official statements
talked about some radar weapons which
most likely they just simply misspoke
their most likely talking about
electronic warfare weapons rib that
sounds a bit like radar in Russian but
is not but there are anti-aircraft I
mean electronic warfare most likely was
used right well I see that Russia is
saying that it was an act of terrorism
that it has the right to retaliate
should Kiev be potentially bracing for
an on-throat what would be a
proportionate response here
well the Russians could attack the
presidential offices in central uh keyf
on Bank of that's quite a possibility of
course right now president zielinski is
not in key of two he went to Finland but
such an attacker could possibly happen
well obviously Kiev is continuing to
deny any kinds of accusations that this
was an assassination attempt we'll be
staying on this story Pavo Falcon how
their defense and Military analyst
speaking to us from Moscow always great
to get your thoughts thank you so much
Pavel well let's now bring in journalist
Julia chapovalova she's also in the
Russian Capital Yuli obviously we're
just getting lots and lots of
information in as we speak talk us
through what we know right now
well actually we have just some official
information from the Quran and we know
that two drones earlier on on Wednesday
tried to Target the presidential
residents in the Kremlin according to
the president's press service they
didn't specify the the type of the
drones uh the military and Intelligence
Officers took some timely actions
according to them they used radar
Warfare systems jamming the signal of
the drones and eventually disabled
disabling the devices uh no one was
injured and the fall of the uavs and
this capturing of their fragments uh no
um no material damage was was uh caused
either uh the head of state hasn't been
heard uh according to to uh the
kremlin's uh spokesperson uh the
kremlin's assessment was that Moscow
considered that type a planned terrorist
act threatening the life of the
president of the Russian Federation
um according to the Press Service uh the
the Russian side now has the right to
take retaliatory measures uh where and
when it is appropriate and obviously
they blamed the Ukrainian side
immediately for that attack uh meanwhile
they say that Putin's schedule
um is not going to change due to that
attack and the president is going to to
work as usual and early on Wednesday he
also met with the governor of the
Nigerian novguru region in one of his
residences and that was reported as well
uh also you know that the v-day parade
will take place no matter what uh the
criminal also said that the attack took
place right before Victory Day uh which
has widely celebrated uh here every day
every year sorry on May the 9th um uh
the incident however will not affect the
kremlin's plans uh um to to you know to
um for the parade to take place on a red
square on May the 9th uh also President
Putin will take part in the celebrations
that's according to the Kremlin uh
shortly before the publication of the
Kremlin statement uh we also heard from
Moscow mayor Sergey serbianen and he
announced a ban on the launch of drones
in the capital
um an exception is made only for devices
used by the authorities
um we also we also heard from Ukraine
and you brain obviously denies any
involvement in that tag on the Kremlin
and we've heard from from the Ukrainian
presidential spokesperson and he said
that they had no information about the
so-called Knight attacks on the Kremlin
but uh
um as president zielinski repeatedly
stated Ukraine directed all available
forces and means to liberate its own
territories and uh not to attack others
and he also called the events in dimitro
in denipro and Uma in a terrorist attack
the attacks that took place a bit
earlier on and what happened in Moscow
was obviously an escalation of the
situation before May the 9th that's
according to the Ukrainian side well
this is clearly a developing story we'll
be staying that staying across it for
you here on altazira Julia chapoval over
there speaking to us from Moscow thank
you Julia